はやめ
ただまだなのに
今起きた今日ははずの質問です最中た皆さんどんなお願い事しましたでしょうか
僕メン愛ということと悩みがありましてあのたぶんね皆さん気付いてないと思う1本
一方深刻に僕はデブの日チョイってます
言うとそのまま太ってないんだけどねかんあ太ってないんですけども問題はお腹よ
横から見てください
はい
い
分かりますははかわかりますか
ちょっと寄ってねあのようやくね自分の体の特徴があれば買ってきたよ基本的に体は
こうまだ全然細いんですけどお腹が
太ってきた分からないもう何かわかんないけどお腹のお肉が確実にちょっとずつついて
きていると思ってますもんだってほらもう美容とちょっとね前までコゼット知ったんだ
けど妻に猛
作られる理由はこう屈んだ時とかも花がブルッってるっと殻が割れないんだよね払われ
ないけどすごいぞ
また3万時間が久兵衛みたいにまだまた戻れるって俺は思ってるなんだあのホールと腹
に俺はモテると思ってるんですけどもうランクして楽したいんですよ人は楽したいん
じゃなかなかにこう体をもっとバキバキにできないかなと思ったときに衝撃的な商品に
言ってやりましたこちらさっき届いたんですけどこれですね
今後んキーチャット強そうでしょ
これすごいんですよ何がすごいかって言いますとなんかネットで見たんですけどネット
の情報が正しければ切りだけで体がバキバキに割れますやぁいっしょ発売開始から
わずか半年で10万枚突破
24時間トレーニングや楽天市場ランキング第1位獲得機ながらボクサー払え
ただの下着だと舐めてるとあなたは衝撃を受けることになる
切れば体感する今後級の力
旦那体を24時間一面だ俺なんか宣伝の瞳対応そうそうコレを着たらもうなんかねから
倒すを引き締めるみたいなことを書いてあるんで
着ているだけで24時間トレーニングしているような感覚があるらしいです
カッコイーカッコイイてが痩せるのかな年間なんかすごい2週間でこれだけ変化しまし
たみたいな画像があって結構変わってますね
2週間でお金のかかるわかんないでもネットの情報
だからの信じがたいなあ
っていうところなんですよネットの一部では2週間で体がバキバキに進化した方までは
全く効果がなかったとっちが正しいか分からんやろ
だから僕がこの筋トレまた重ねて筋肉ほぼないこと状態の金型鋼合金 t シャツを
着ることによってどこまでケンカするか検証していきましょう
とりあえずどんなものかというのがまた見てみたいんですよね見た目からまずすごい
っていう話を聞いたの a
待って
これお前だーえしまって皆さんサイズ的には上まっですね
俺だってこんなの聞いたら死んじゃうゾネバーって何て西松屋さん完全に僕は今から
アーちゃん開けるようなにしまったような復興切って体を今日の子が引き締められ続け
て体がこう鍛えられるみたいないっていうんだと思いますはんんんこれマジ官はこれ
吉慶の大変な
待ってこれじゃあきりの新で辛抱
じゃあヤバヤバうわぁ
まあ頑張って女の人みたいなやつうわこれヤバイぞ
待ってたねまだはこれすごいなぁよこいやこれこれ
うわぁやばいこれスーパーこれができるはまっすぐうわーっうわーっなく島にい旅立つ
ルクエちょっと引き締められてますこれで自分じゃないんだな効果があるか分からない
んですけどすごいし訳されている感じはちゃんとあります
こうやって普通
のシャツ着てもねあんまりバレないっていうね2点ありますああ
はいというわけで多分大体2週間くらいかなー3週間ぐらいちょっとこれを着続けて僕
の身体の変化を見てみたいと思いますでは皆さん2週間後を楽しみにたくさん買っとい
て良かった
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ